Today, we're going to be speaking to economist
Ariel Rubenstein, professor of economics at
Tel Aviv University and at New York University.
Thank you so much for your time.
I appreciate speaking with you.
My pleasure.
So one of the really two areas that are very
much in right now in economics are game theory
and behavioral economics.
And if one reads critiques of these areas,
one of the things I read frequently is that
as interesting as game theory and behavioral
economics are to study theoretically that
there is a limit to what these fields of study
can tell us about the real world.
Do you believe that this is a fair criticism?
It's a very fair criticism.
And I would sign on every word that U.S. officials
say.
You know, every area is probably in the sciences
and also as in life, as information, in other
things in politics.
Then we have waves and the waves, not because
somebody discovered the light or discovered
something.
They going to go on the waves because some
sort of social pressures inside the academic
world.
So when I was very young then what we called
general equilibrium was dominating economics
then actually I was a part of what is called
the theoretical evolution in economics.
And that's became so fashionable that actually
younger these almost don't know general equilibrium.
And and the next wave was behavioral economics.
And the next wave is probably something which
is very far from some theoretical development.
But in any case, this is, first of all, the
fact that something is dominating the field
inside economics does not mean that this is
true.
It is really mean.
It does mean that is dominating.
It's also true.
It should be say that economics is probably
again is any other political group is very
much there is there is a little bit the tyranny
of the government, meaning of the dominating
field.
And when something is on top, then it's quite
rejects.
The other fits my position about economics,
economic theory in general, that it's not
about truth, it's not about tools.
Nothing is too it's a little bit like literature.
You know, sometimes there is a face.
There is one type of literature.
It's more fashionable.
Another time, another type of literature is
very fresh in my attitude in general to general
to economic theory that this is a bunch of
stories about if you wanted a bunch of fables.
Now, these families are not completely disconnected
from the world.
They are connected with the world.
But in remind you that also Disney fables
are connected to the web.
So it's connected to the world.
It's about the world in some sense, but not
in the direct way that people think or many
people take it.
And now, regarding a continuing in this line,
when we think about getting to where, you
know, I spent much of my life doing emptily
and I don't do into anymore, I should say,
I move to get to it the those nullity.
And then these days I'm doing things which
are more connected to general equilibrium
than to get to it.
And and that's not because there was this
I was distributed through again.
So I've never believed I've never understood
that to me is some concrete listening to a
message to the world.
And when other people and some of them are
very respectable people that I admire on their
academic achievements, try to claim that,
get to it tells something about politics,
about life, about religion or whatever.
I feel very angry, I should say.
Do you think, though, that over time we will
get closer to economic theory that really
does tell us more or is more highly applicable
in the real world than I guess the idea would
be.
We had this initial school of economics that
was based on perfectly rational actors.
And then over time we learned, OK, that's
not exactly the way things work.
Let's introduce behavioral economics, which
at least claimed to get closer to accounting
for the psychology of the real world and maybe
gets us a little closer.
Do you think over time we will get closer
and closer?
No, you don't know nothing, that means that
categorically not in the means that we work
on.
Now, of course, it may be the case that in
our point of time, in some sense, I hope that
it's after I will I will go from this world
that the world will be so different that there
will be some that that we will be the way
to model David, or it would not be the way,
the formal way or the absolute way that we
do it.
But it will be we will play people think it
will think about us indeed as machines, really
machines as the sort of collection of of atoms
or a collection of cells that somehow interact
in some way.
And people will someday will understand that
decoded.
And then we will start to be David and there
will be some sort of organisms in the world.
And then there will be so much different than
the world that we live in that, you know,
the question of whether economic theory will
do the work or not is completely unimportant.
And it will be completely I cannot imagine
such a world now.
I cannot say that it's impossible.
You know who I am.
I'm not a scientist and I'm an economist.
So I have to say that that's impossible one
day.
But I, I personally, I in in continuing continue
is developing.
The theory is even making it more empirically
in some sense irrelevant.
I don't think that we are as close because
and again, the analogy is the analogy of literature.
Do you believe that one day there will be
a book that in some sense will explain the
world in the better ways to ever read?
It will say, wow, no, I understand the politics
of the US and I predict the elections.
And in 2024, I maybe I, I cannot I cannot
imagine something like you mentioned bounded
rationality.
And I want to talk about that a little bit,
maybe for the people in our audience who are
less familiar with some of these concepts.
In general, when we talk about rationality
in economics, what do we mean?
And then what do you mean when we talk about
more specifically bounded rationality?
Well, the way that I mean, amount of optionality,
I mean that in the story, namely what we call
a model in our language, but it's I think
about it's just a story.
There is a concrete element of the procedural
aspect of decision making, that's all.
And when we talk about the importance with
rationality, actually, we also have a sort
of a procedure.
But the procedure is in some sense perfect.
In some logical sense, people can do in whatever
calculations.
They fully understand the probabilistic laws
and think it's a good step.
On the other hand, when people are limited
and all of us are limited and we take it into
account or we put it, we don't take into account,
we know it.
I think about it more that we put it explicitly
into the model that there are some aspects
of rationality and it's become a model.
But that's all.
That's all.
But of course, in the interpretation of what
we do, this is a big step.
It's a big step because it's it's makes some
of the results of many of the results that
are coming in the model when we assume full
optionality is different, that's all.
So would it be fair to say that would it be
fair to say that rationality is a broad concept,
is a more theoretical concept.
Bounded rationality accounts for the real
world limits of rationality?
I don't know.
I you know, if you take, you know, the example
that I often give is that, again, the characters
in Disney, in Disney movies, cartoons, these
movies are usually very simple in the sense
that although they are good or bad, right.
It's either they're evil or take that there
are to extremes.
And now we can think about the way that people
are.
Either of them have some sort of a clique
in their minds.
Is evil one either good or bad?
That's the end of the story.
And then see the interaction between many
good and bad people in different situations.
Now we can complicate it and think about the
situation is more and more involved in more
include some sort of in-between, between being
good and bad at many cultures and between
being fully rational and being completely
random.
There is also a lot of varieties and when
we are interested in the way that this procedural
aspect effect the interaction between human
beings and it becomes about those reality
now is it's closer.
I don't like to think about it the closer
I think that it's different.
And again, closer and behind your assumptions
is there is this goal, which is that economic
theory will be will predict the world will
be will fit the description of the world as
close as possible.
I personally, I must say, I've never wanted
to predict anything.
I don't want to predict I want to I want to
to do interesting story to it, to invent interesting
stories.
Full stop.
What if interesting stories is do to the world?
Well, you know, there are some interesting
stories that were written by people much more
famous than me that really changed the world.
And and and and I don't think that the type
of model that we deal with will change the
way that they affect the way that economists
or what people are doing social sciences or
think about social sciences or person like
you would think about it, about the world.
But this is in a very indirect way.
The influence is exactly, in my opinion, almost
exactly like literature.
Probably the difference is that there is that
there is I don't think that when people read
the novel, they say they have expectations
that everything will be correct except describe
the world and see what they are.
And also the influence of of course, there
are some writers who were becoming prime ministers
and presidents and so on.
But most of the writers do not do whatever
they do in the in the direct relation to politicians
or to people who do public affairs.
The difference between this respect between
writers and in the economy is that there is
I think that most of the people, including
many of my friends, economists and definitely
people who think about economics and people
who write in The Wall Street Journal or in
the economic section, in newspapers and so
on.
Approach economies with the expectation that
they will tell them things which are very,
very useful now.
Now, you know, some people believe that economics
is, of course, is much more useful in the
direct sense than me.
And I you know, I think that the burden of
proof is on them.
Not only am I, it's not my goal.
I never I've never given any advice to anybody.
And I'm not going to give you guys not.
Well, that's fair.
So so putting aside for a moment the idea
of predictive utility, can you talk maybe
about some examples of situations that we
can maybe better understand by understanding
bounded rationality?
What types of real world, real world world
problems might we better understand under
this umbrella?
And to be honest, it's a very if you ask me
now, a very tough question.
I don't think that I can it would be such
a tiny move for me now to in a few minutes
to to say, OK, here is an example of such
and such.
When I was doing McGimpsey, when I was asked
many times the same question, and so probably
I was I fell into the trap and answer these
questions, some examples of when I ended the
interview or whatever, and I said, oh, come
on, I did this this thing and nobody understood.
And in the end, what I meant and look at the
economic zone in many respects, it's it's
it's a it's a study of the way that economists
think.
And it's very difficult.
And sometimes it's very dangerous to transfer
the terms directly in the public.
By the way, that's the success you mentioned
the behavioral economics, the big success,
the public success will be able economics
is because the whole economy is a very direct
communication with the public.
Why?
Because actually many of the examples in the
story is that they can work simple and actually
makes a lot of sense.
And many of them are not very good academic
achievements.
But it is just common sense.
And and therefore, you know, you can give
a speech about economics and people will be
very excited because they will feel that actually
they understand the lecture and actually they
feel that they themselves knew some of the
stuff that is doing and so on.
I mean, is that is that that's an important
bias maybe to understand.
Right.
The idea that that which can be more easily
understood, people may be more likely to believe
it is accurate, but that may not be the case,
that it's not on not only the U.S. economy
is one of the big effects in the last few
years is what is called let's call it the
NAHJ movement.
The nudge movement is almost the political
movements these days.
It's also the listeners that they don't know
what it is.
It is some a very respectable economist.
And not only economists, lawyers and other
scientists believe that what is called a libertarian
paternalism, namely, we don't want to force
people to to take the vaccination.
Let's say that's an issue now in Israel.
But we don't want to force them into religion
to force them.
But we can match them to to to to study some
ways that we engage them more effectively.
Now, behind this this, of course, is the Israel
has a lot of debates in the last few years
about the philosophical status of liberty.
And personally, I'm very much against this
movement because of many reasons.
One of them that I believe that people know
it's not that it's not connected with economics,
it just makes my views.
I believe in the personal responsibility to
a person.
And I also believe that clever people or people
or economists or scholars who believe that
they are very clever, don't know what is good
to do other people more than the people themselves.
And I feel that the manipulation of people's
ideas, not the people, even with the best
intentions, they manipulate other people to
do something.
I feel that it's for me it is the person which
is immoral in almost almost all applications.
So in a sense, in a sense, all the questions
about capitalism and not actually I think
that there's very little to do with the academic
research.
These are ideas that we can discuss and in
in debating about in the afternoon or in the
evening dinner or the table and discuss them.
And and probably you will have some insights
as a person who is connected with human beings,
not least as many of the scholars of of of
variable economics.
So I think that, again, it's not about economics.
There's not any interesting.
Stories, it is, but the but the potential
to be able economics to be more realistic
and more and especially the the the the move,
which is almost a political move that you
are trying to claim.
We know how to do something and we actually
are behind the scenes actually manipulate
other people
in
the name of academic ideas.
I
think this made so many angles that they can
think about.
Well, we've been speaking with Ariel Rubenstein,
who is professor of economics at Tel Aviv
University and at New York University.
Professor.
Such a pleasure speaking with you today.
I appreciate your time.
My pleasure